foreign
[Music]
guys what's up it's congratulations but
also what I want to tell you isn't that
like a what is this that's like a devil
thing right great people are gonna go
nuts that I open the show with that
um I got shows coming out in Richmond
Virginia Baltimore uh Maryland and
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
chrisley.com uh they are on sale now
um uh and then I also I'm gonna be in a
bunch of different places I will be in
uh Ohio this week so get your tickets
May 6 Columbus and May 7th Cincinnati uh
then Boise and uh Tucson Pueblo Colorado
and Colorado Springs I think I'll be um
yeah I'll be in Cleveland also October
20th so get those anyway welcome to the
episode whatever it is of
congratulations
crazy crazy congratulations
[Music]
we're doing it right it's nice
um
and uh we're having a good time took my
magic mind with my coffee today and it's
absolutely ripping
um but I am
uh uh being absolutely chill
um everything is all good I I woke up uh
this morning
well actually last night
I this is
actually hilarious last night
I uh
uh what is it now today
today's we're recording on Monday so
it's episode 313. Sunday night
I was with my buddy we were hanging out
at the house
and I go to take my trash out now if you
know your boy
he's got the trash can under the first
under the second level it's on the
driveway so I pop out most of the [__]
that goes down in my house goes on the
second level first level adds for
suckers it's just you know the garage
and a little bit of an entryway
second level that's mostly where I
reside third level bedroom fourth level
helicopter pad okay so I I am going to
take the trash out because the trash is
in the driveway right because I keep my
bins in the driveway
I go over to take the trash drop it out
the top
aim it right never missed
Let It Go as I let it go ring goes
pink pink in
the trash can
trash can is
horribly full this
is very small so this is obviously
at the bottom okay because it's just
gonna [__]
like one of those what is it those games
I mean bad analogy so um
so
I
I it's 1am and I go like this charge it
to the game I'm not this the day's
already over I'm not there's no I I
there's no way it's cold I got I got
only underwear on like I'm gonna go
shift through the trash now all right
not only is it diaper not only is it a
uh
um trash can full full of also
turd-filled diapers from a two week old
right because uh William
won't stop excreting I mean it's like he
excretes as much as Daddy farts okay
it's unbelievable so
there's so many diapers with [__] in it
and it's full completely all right so
I'm like all right you know what charge
into the game sometimes you just gotta
go like that you know when stuff happens
and you just go okay all right well that
is something that happened I'm not gonna
deal I'm not ready to deal with that
emotionally I'm just gonna that's the
end of the day tomorrow not only will
the ring still be there because nobody's
gonna
skip through no one knows the Ring's
there right
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna wait
till tomorrow because tomorrow I'm gonna
wake up it's gonna be
sunshiny I can see where I'm going I'll
get the right gloves I'll get a thick
because I do it I get the The Mask I'm
not going in I'm like I'm gonna puke
right you ever smell trash is the worst
so
so I wake up the next day
raining
trash can still open so now not only is
it filled with shitty diapers and
disgusting old like pizza boxes that's
all it's like it's like [__] soup well
I'm actually getting so nauseous even
thinking about that
so it's like a pizza old you know shitty
diapers just trash and it's soup and my
ring is somewhere in the bottom
so I'm like oh I should have got it last
night
but maybe
I'll be able to like at least see better
so I go down
I get the gloves on I get the mask on my
wife's like you don't need the mask I
was like I need the mask okay
I'm not putting my head in a trap I
don't even know how I'm gonna do this
yet I'm getting it all set up so I go
down
take a piece of trash take the trash I
dumped last night still in the bag put
it in another trash can got two trash
cans absolutely
you know got to trash cans I was gonna
hit the the Brinks button but it's not
up yet that's great perfect
um
and I take another Pizza I take a pizza
box out
why I said Pizza one time um
one time a guy at a Mexican restaurant
said you want pizza Mexican pizza
I was like isn't Pizza Pizza in Spanish
um
Pizza p-i-k-s-a
or pixa
um
cool the sound plan isn't working that's
amazing
so nothing ever Works in this podcast
that's fine though it's me it's my it's
my thing it's all good nothing is coming
up so that's great yes so anyway I'm
gonna have to reset it awesome I can't
reset it because we're going all right
well you know what no sound boards
um
it's not
you want me to give it to you
how do we do it whatever dude where I'm
deeply deep in a story so uh
so I go I take a few things out of the
thing and then dude there's like a wheel
well in the trash can because my
my I would also use the brakes truck
here because my my charge can has wheels
on it but of course that's all good
um that's funny thing to brag about but
uh you know my soundboard doesn't have
my back but it's all good so so I I in
the wheel well it indents in on the
trash can my ring is sitting on the
wheel well I don't even have to turn my
trash can over at all I'm like dude this
is this is absolutely fantastic
so I go to
um
grab the ring
pick it up awesome
look down
[__] smeared all over my shirt because
of the [__] Edge yes dude oh dude
he's got [__] titties right
wait wait oh it just got me oh it just
got mail I got [__] titties oh it just
got me
so that's how my day started AES dude
all good
um can I actually reset my computer and
will it be okay or will everything go to
stop recording I can do it all right
cool well then that's what we're gonna
do
mute what
so it doesn't go
[Music]
yeah dude because it would wouldn't it
we do it so
um so that's cool I got my ring and life
didn't win did it I won I won against
life that's that's that's [__]
because I get I get I do I get pissed
off when that happens
my computer's resetting so I can get the
thing that's amazing I need to buy my
computer I could be from 1994. I saw I
was watching this uh new uh uh TV show
called like the best collectibles or
whatever on Netflix and it's this guy
and he uh he just basically gets all the
Collectibles and runs a business and has
an auction for his Collectibles and
knows a lot of private investors and
[__] and sorry private uh collectors and
he just his whole business is putting
collectibles on auction and one of the
things was uh
the first uh Mac computer and it was um
really shitty it was it didn't even have
like a [__] case on it whatever
that's boring but this is the [__] that
you get to when my computer resets
um so I got my ring back and I felt bad
too because when I went to bed I was
like actually sad that my ring was in
the trash because I was like man that
sucks it's like my that's like my
wedding that's my my my marriage and
like it's technically like in the trash
right now the ring the thing that
symbolizes it and then I was like I felt
a little bit better because I was like
it wasn't the ring my wife got me
actually on the day she got me the gold
one this was the one that I got later
and it's [__] um platinum and that's
very interesting and everyone goes like
this when I say that when everyone's
listening they go like this oh really
when I say that
I'm probably the number one podcast
where people go like this too oh really
out loud
that's how interesting I am
oh [__] no you don't say like you're
driving along your [__] you go like this
huh that's what you do when you listen
to congratulations [__] PR
um
so yeah so I feel good and then
dude Calvin reasoned with me for the
first time today was [__] hilarious
we got a bunch of balloons because it's
uh it was David Sullivan's birthday and
my wife is an absolute Maniac when it
comes to celebrating anything and she's
if there's a way to spend money she
doesn't she doesn't overspend but if
there's a way to spend money a little
bit of money like if my wife can spend
30 on something she's in and what I mean
by that is not as opposed to 400 as
opposed to just not doing something
like my wife will be like oh it's uh
Tim's birthday let's get him stuff and
I'm like who's Tim your friend no Tim
was the guy that you met
um twice in the park
I'm let's make him a pie come on we're
going to Ralph's and I'm like no I don't
want it just get in
and then she'll just and it's 30.
everything is thirty dollars
that she wants to celebrate and she's
good she's Thrifty but it's but it's too
many of the things that are happening
so we go to get balloons
um and we go to get balloon you know I'm
like I'm gonna go get coffee I was like
babe why don't you come with me it's fun
to get coffee we'll take little chillium
we'll take William
we'll take what's the dillium
and uh we'll take Billy boys what Calvin
Calvin's been calling them it's very
cute and um and we'll take it we'll
we'll put them in the cars that's the
most annoying thing is putting a baby in
the car seat it's really hard a baby
baby not a toddler a baby baby it's like
every time I put a baby in the car seat
my my baby and my William or if it
whenever I put Calvin when he was a baby
baby in the car seat I'm like oh this is
his last ride he's just gonna
his their Chin's just
you know and you're like all right I I
hope we make it to [__] I I hope we
make it to the park
because they can't be like hey fix it
right you're just driving and they're
just
so I Buckle them up and oh so sorry
let's go and she's like no and she's
like you know what actually let's go we
will go because I gotta get stuff for
David anyway I have to spend thirty
dollars
so guys what do we get she's like we're
gonna get balloons and we're gonna get
steaks because he's from Texas and he
likes steak and we're gonna get steak
and I'm gonna make steak and I'm gonna
get balloons I'm gonna get a cowboy
themed balloons and I'm like you're a
[__] nut job you're my angel but
hello nut job right
hello nut job my wife you spend thirty
dollars on Cowboy balloon
why do you do this at every chance you
get why are you always spending thirty
five dollars
Let It Go I met the guy three times he's
a friend of a friend
we could use that 35 for Calvin
so anyway
um
we go I'm like cool my wife's gonna come
up with a coffee awesome my young man is
gonna come over to Coffee yes I'm gonna
have William and I'm gonna have Kristen
we're gonna coffee we're gonna leave
Calvin with the nanny it's on dude
hell yeah it's back dude it is back we
reset and it was on mute and I had to
put it off mute in the middle because
that's what one fire decided that would
be better when I turned the computer on
when I reset it and I did it and it was
wrong because it cut out the Jeremy
renders thing in the middle of it so
therefore one fire anyway dude it's all
good we go we get the balloons and it
takes two long yes dude
yo have you ever tried to get balloons
Don't It Takes Two long worst game show
yay hi welcome to it takes too long your
wife's gonna go get balloons today how
long are you gonna take uh Phil
um
30 minutes
oh you're a [__] loser how could you
think it would be so little maybe for
you right but your wife's got to go like
this a lot
oh it took 42 minutes and she's gonna
leave you with the baby in the car
because she said I'll just take a second
oh
so I'm staying in the car she finally
comes out she goes oh no she comes to my
car she says hey sorry she goes on car
with no balloons and she says hey sorry
I need your credit card I left mine at
home oh [__] dude oh but bring all the
things
my wife is the least bringing all the
things bringing us to all the things
chick in the world and I understand she
has to bring a lot of things right you
gotta bring diapers you gotta be wet
wipes you gotta bring both babies you
gotta bring [__] your wallet too and
she did and that's fine whatever
so
she brings out balloons they're a it's a
cow balloon and a a friggin horse and
different color balloons so it's funny
it is funny I'll give it to her we'll
put in the back with the baby can't see
behind me very dangerous with the baby
all good
um then we gotta go to the grocery store
and get meats and that's all good we go
I wait in the car again she takes two
long yay and I get out of the car I take
the baby I'm like where is she and I
walk in I'm holding the baby and
everyone's like oh my God how old and
I'm like I'm 43 thank you and um
and I get there and she says uh oh my
God it's so cool to see you and the baby
out together like I and without even
knowing it like I saw it it just melts
my heart I was like that's amazing I'm
still pissed because it's taking so long
but that's a very sweet thing to say so
we get in the car we go home and Calvin
sees the balloons and dude he runs so
fast to the balloons and he says oh my
and gets the balloons he's playing with
the balloons for a bunch he's got now
they're all together in a sandbag
hanging out we take one of the balloons
off and we put it on Williams
wrist so he's just like sitting there
holding the balloon and it's bopping up
and down Calvin knows now that you can
separate the balloons so he leaves the
room for a little bit and it comes back
and he this is he reasoned with me for
the first time ever he comes up to me
and he says I want the cow one I want
the cow balloon and I look at him
because sometimes I just sit and I wait
for him to finish the thought because
it's so beautiful and so sweet to watch
his brain work he says I want the cow
balloon and I waited and he said and he
said it's so long
like the reason was
it's long the string is long to the cow
and he was like I mean it's fine it's so
long you can we can
wasn't even a good reason but still he
tried and for that
I cut it off and gave it to him
and then he I had to change his diaper I
took the diaper off as soon as I took it
off he took his finger put it directly
in his butt and then put it directly in
his nose so I had the cow in a very high
pitched voice tell him that little boys
shouldn't put their fingers in their
butts
[Applause]
your finger should never go away in your
butt
it your finger at least if it goes into
your butt the last place it should go
after that
is in your nose
nice cabin
um so anyway dude that's what's been up
I lost my ring and my son put his finger
on his butt and put it in his nose cool
cool cool
um
so what you know what else is going on
you know it's like
we have a good time we have a good time
here congratulations like And subscribe
leave a uh uh what do you call it um
comment for the algorithm And subscribe
baby
[Music]
um
they uh they reinstated a
what's his name her name
Amber Heard uh to play uh
[__] Shamu or whatever the goddamn
name is I don't know the [__] stupid
Aquaman shits you know
what's his name Enrique Obama what's his
[__] name the [__] guy who plays
it
Jason Momoa Enrique Obama
ah
it's name dude Enrique Obama
um Jason Momoa dude anyway uh she's
gonna be in the in the Aquaman [__]
too many whatever the [__] new one is
Aquaman four however many you know what
you could tell me that there's two
Aquaman's and you could be like there's
11 Aquaman's and I would have the same
reaction I'd be like yeah probably I
don't know I don't have a [__] clue
but she's gonna be back as Aqua woman or
whatever the [__] Shira I don't know
whatever the Hell she's gonna be flipper
and um
you know
that's crazy that is so crazy to me by
the way she should be oh oh Cyrus or
whatever the [__] her name is right
I don't give a [__] but it is crazy that
they will just reinstate a woman
and if it's a dude they're [__] ow
dude they're out
they're out
a guy could like bump into a lady and
he's done forever by the way and when a
chick is like lying about the [__]
this world is mad dude and then I love
how people are like fine they're not
getting my 15 like who gives a [__] cope
I dude
everybody does everything
you know she's gonna be [__] who
she's gonna be she's obviously terrible
she's a terrible person because of all
the [__] but also we don't even
really know what happened who the [__]
knows
who the relationship was probably toxic
who the [__] knows but
um she's back she's back as the [__]
lady in Aquaman and uh
that's what's up
so I guess they're going to cut me back
into [__] Army the dead now
um
release the Delia cut dude
release the Delia caught my baby
um
this world is mad dude this world is mad
mad world
Mad World
[Music]
guys I want to talk to you about ship
station now listen when it comes to
saving money as a small business owner
which I am and many of you are every
little bit helps ship station gives you
access to discounts of up to 84 off of
USPS and UPS rates check that out and
you can manage every order from one
simple to use dashboard take it from me
I am not tech savvy I use this and it is
amazing it's so easy uh when you lower
your shipping costs and make returns
easy your customers stay happy while you
save money okay running merch for me can
be stressful no doubt of course uh but
having ship station in our Corner makes
everything easier with their dashboard
it's great thank you shipstation
shipstation hooks you up with industry
leading discounts so you'll never have
to worry about overpaying uh for
shipping get up to 84 off the like I
said the USPS rates and the UPS rates if
that's not enough use my promo code so
you get that and then also use my promo
code to try shipstation free for the
next two months okay
look 130 000 companies are not wrong
they've grown their e-commerce business
with ship station 98 of companies that
stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life it really
helps it's good for your business worry
less about the bottom line when you save
money with ship station go to
shipstation.com and use code congrats
today and sign up for your free 60-day
trial that's shipstation.com code
congrats
crazy crazy
hey you guys know about mood or do you
live under a rock look whether you're
new to cannabis or an Old Pro there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem iffy at best all right so
when you want to relax iffy yeah it's
not going to cut it it's the last thing
you want to feel you can't relax you
feel iffy all right so mood puts an end
to guessing games it's 100 federally
legal Delta eight and Delta 9 THC you
can have shipped right to you just
straight to you no doctors no waiting
just Affordable Legal THC one and Ivan
the producer of this podcast say it is
the way to shop for weed uh you shop by
mood like uh Focus euphoric or creative
the product is incredible and price
great they've been enjoying uh euphoric
gummies they said and fruity crispy
treats and THC moon rocks uh they said
it was easy to order and got there very
fast so uh mood offers federally legal
forms of THC extracted from hemp plants
and uh they're also great taste of
gummies classic flower convenient
pre-rolls and so much more ready for a
good time without the guesswork we'll
check it out order your THC products
from mood today and for 20 off your
first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use promo code
congrats that's hello
m-o-d.com promo code congrats for 20 off
your order and free gummies
[Music]
I was watching this thing on Hulu the
[__] Grand wizard Grand Knight
Nighthawk Wizard or whatever the [__]
the KKK do the KK has the dorkiest names
hey wizard
hey
dude you're a 45 year old guy
wizard you know and so cumbersome their
outfits yeah like just like can't sit
down gotta move it a little bit to sit
down dude
I want to join the KKK because I want to
be like guys guys I don't know man
I'm here for the uh I'm gonna be the
[__] uh not to play Devil's Advocate
right
well yeah truly The Devil's Advocate
guys maybe just regular Advocate I don't
know if we should be doing all that
um but yeah so I watched this thing
called like Grand Hawk night wizard what
the hell is it called it's on Hulu it's
a kid documentary
Grand Nighthawk so [__]
dorky dude hi I'm the grand Nighthawk
huh
what
Steve
that's so dorky
dude KKK will be like oh dude dragon
dragons and wizards dork
so dorky like I'm that my problem isn't
the racism my problem is dude call each
other cooler [__]
call each other I know I understand you
can't have the you got to kind of go by
pseudonyms and you got to also dude just
I'm sorry but wizard dude
call myself wizard my nizzard
um
what's up hey guys I'm the grand wizard
I'm the grand Wheezy my neezy
[Laughter]
here to cut this meeting uh sup with the
blacks anyway
sorry I don't really have an outline
today but uh it was going on with the
it's API API aipi
or whatever
API I like the [__] um
stutter King what's the [__] called
King speech wow I don't know anything
anymore dude straight up I called Jason
Momoa Enrique Obama
so uh yeah I watched this thing where
this guy basically
infiltrated the KKK
also
Ku Klux Klan is dorky dude the whole
thing is
so just call it Dungeons and Dragons for
whites
um
so I'm watching this thing
and this guy they get this guy who isn't
I don't even he was like a military guy
and they get him to go undercover as a
KKK guy
um
and he goes in
and he's like you gotta stake it out and
see what's going on if they're gonna
like do anything [__] up let us know
turns out that in the 80s or 90s he
tried to do this already
and he was undercover in the KKK guy
with the KKK guys for the FBI and the
and he told his wife about it and they
ceased it like the information the uh
Mission went they're like we're done
your wife knows you can't do it and it
was like wow they don't [__] around and
that's dope right it's compromised it's
compromised dude how badly do you want
to say that if you're in the [__] you
know what it's compromised
that makes you feel like a real mad it's
compromise anytime you could say it's
compromised as a man you got to say it's
compromised dude
the milk's compromised man a little drop
of water got in it
[__] man we left the cheese out for ah
it was five hours as compromise man it's
sweaty is it she's sweaty it's
compromised
you put your finger in your butt you
can't put in your nose your nose is
compromised let's get come on
so um
so this guy
gets a second chance at going undercover
to the KKK which is like the craziest
second chance
like Redemption is always about a second
chance
but this guy's second chance was hey I
[__] up
in my mission going undercover to the FB
undercover to the KKK and 20 years later
I get my second chance to go undercover
the KKK which is wow this is like oh so
I'm in okay guy is from Jacksonville
looks totally normal and is white like
the number one guy that could be from
this is why they they picked the guy
because they were like he's it's him
look at him
he's from Jacksonville and he's a
[__] they they want military guys
like the KKK
gets so like jizztastic over guys who
have actual skills because a lot of them
losers you know and I don't mean this as
like I'm not hating on any group
dude even though kind of that's their
thing
but a lot of KKK guys are like they live
at their mom's place because this is
where they find a lot of people in many
in any groups really if you're part of
any group pretty much you've
the jury's out on you right don't ever
be a part of a group
and don't ever volunteer for anything
that's what my grandfather said I'm
gonna get that tattooed across my back
don't ever volunteer for anything so um
so he goes undercover again
and the dude the guys are just like
a year in they're like
they were these um
prison guards
and a guy one of the inmates one of the
prison guards blew smoke into the
inmate's face they made said please
don't is black inmate he said please
don't and he kept doing it and they made
punch him in the face and bit him
provoke the inmate right now whatever
both in the in the wrong of course but
don't be blowing smoke on my face you
blow smoke on my face man that's the
last face you're gonna blow smoking okay
and that's kristalia who said it
so you can imagine a guy that this
inmate was in so this happened and then
he got out of jail he's paid his time
did his time got out of jail and then
the prison cops were like dude
uh
uh we got we gotta kill this
[__] right
so the three three the three prison cops
were white guys in the KKK so they asked
this guy who's undercover hey dude this
guy he bit me and now he's out he fought
me and now he's out and we gotta we
gotta get him and he goes You Wanna Give
me the undercover guy says you want me
to give him a Stern talking to and he
says no he says you want me to beat him
up a little he says no and he says you
want to put him six feet deep and he
says uh-huh and the guy goes and tells
the FBI they wire him up dude he wears a
wire for nine
years dude
imagine wearing a wire once dude if I
wore a wire once
around bad guys you know what kind of
audio you're getting this is the audio
again
do you piss yourself
why does it smell like [__] in here
[Laughter]
you look bad Chris
why are you so white
I know you're usually really white but
now you're really really wide
did you piss and [__] this is the uh I
don't know I must have ate something
dude I would have eaten so many things
and then I but guys I must have ate
something sorry I'm just I'm why are you
sweating
so
for nine years this guy you got to be a
sociopath right to do this I want to be
undercover so bad dude but like I
couldn't do it with cake Edition I'd
have to go and like pretend I was a
Target worker and people would keep
people would keep being like are you
Chris Aaliyah and I'd be like no I I
don't know what you're talking about
um I have to go put a toilet paper in
the aisles
I will be in toy section
um
so
yeah so he he he had to he dude it was
crazy what they have to do dude
they have to go
they got this they got the guy they so
they faked the guy's death that's what
they do when you hire someone to kill
someone they fake the death they they
take a picture and then you take the
picture as the undercover guy to the
guys who asked for it to be done and
then you say hey look did it and then
you got to be like is this what you
wanted and then these idiots are like
hell yeah
and the guy one of the guys got four
years dude and the other two got like 12
years that's not enough
so now the guy's [__] the undercover
guy switched his name
and left town and made this documentary
because it's on Hulu and he was like uh
I made this documentary because
I keep getting calls from KKK they know
where I am anyway so I want the world to
know my truth this way if I die you know
how it happened dude and I'm just like
you're so different than me
you actually do [__]
me
comedian me
podcaster me
just a guy you know what I did today
dug through the trash to get my ring
okay know what I did got frustrated
because my wife was in the balloon store
for too long oh you went undercover to
the KKK oh you better than me
it's all good my day is coming dude I
could be a [__] marine biologist one
day
um I could save Dolphins anyway it's
called the Grand dork wizard [__]
dragon or whatever the hell it's called
I don't know anymore man
ah
I uh
I don't know anymore
where's that [__] thing I was looking
at I'm pissed
oh that's not it that's not it so that's
great
um
no what is this [__] stick with me guys
oh you just got me yes got me
did the Met Gala did it already happen
or is it happening again it's happening
right now all right so it will have
happened so uh it's dorky how about that
uh and I guess
who's I spice
that's gonna be the person I don't know
who it is and I'm not don't ever tell me
that's gonna be the thing I don't want
to know who it is I want to be the old
guy who's like I don't know that person
and I'm never gonna know that person you
ever get pissed off when somebody tells
you who someone is and you're like I
should have known who the [__] that was
that's who I spice is
ice spice
the Met Gala is uh
oh don't you cat um
doji cat debuts at the Met Gala in
Sharpay drag is it drag hey
yeah she's not really in drag she's more
of just a cat
you know hey you're not
it's not Dragon you're just a cat okay
I love how they have to be like if you
were bi or non-binary you got to be like
yo
this person is sexy as [__]
like legit
you cannot say somebody who's not who's
non-binary is not good looking you have
to otherwise you'll just get a [__]
oh there's Sydney Sweeney
um
Hey Sydney Sweeney sup
Margot Robbie Robbie take okay
hey Margot Robbie
sup
Ashley Graham
whoa it looks like she's floating on
that that's crazy
um and then there's always somebody that
I don't know who they are here we go
these are the people I don't know could
you imagine being at the Met Gala and
you're oh this guy dude Moss family who
oh the the Kate Moss and then dude could
you imagine being at the Met Gala
imagine dude imagine being at the Met
Gala and you're some guy that you think
that maybe like nobody like you know you
gotta be next to like Michael B Jordan
and you're just like
like you're the [__] second lead on
um
the [__] NCIS or some [__]
and you just you've got a ticket for
thirty thousand dollars because you've
been on the show for 10 years and you're
like I could afford it
and you're just the guy who goes like
this every episode
you know what I'm way ahead of you
got him located
and you just show up with like a [__]
dick on your forehead and you're like is
this it is this what it is
um
so Doja cat is a cat man if I ever go to
the [__] Met Gala Awards or whatever
the [__] it's called well I would never
will but I'm going straight up [__]
nude
oh sorry I didn't understand the
assignment
oh oh you're gonna step on my dick
um
so yeah
all this [__] is just like the [__]
you know what for every celebs they're
just like us there's this [__]
oh this girl looks [__] dope as [__]
um
this is cultural appropriation culture
I just want to go in the stands and just
keep y'all out that's cultural
appropriation
here's uh
this is a thing that
Jared Leto is doing he is a [__] cat
oh he took the doji cat I mean this
guy's just a guy got the furry community
up in arms he's a whole cat this outfit
this costume
uh literally 750 000 you know
I mean he's a cat with like great eyes a
large cat
I don't understand anymore
I'm just like done thank God now is the
time I can be old hey how you doing
today
grateful what's your name where you from
Pharrell
um my name is Pharrell Williams I'm from
uh Virginia Beach Virginia absolutely
dude Pharrell always has the worst
glasses on that it's like unbelievable
they're like he'll be wearing like
little condom rings with twisty ties
attached to him and he's just like
really bad um VA is definitely in the
house stop playing with them Pharrell we
see her looking describe your fit for us
today oh it's that thing oh uh
um human race hoodie okay how much is
Pharrell had sex with seven women from
Italy yeah and here and he says stuff
like I don't like when it's too wet down
there
um
Celine I'd rather it be dry a little bit
honestly you know Selena denim human
race okay clean practice damn
um you see the accessories Doodles hat
uh-huh doodles
okay sorry about that
wow he looks all he looks truly awful
you know
you look just truly atrocious oh if you
had your friends over and you're like my
friend's coming in he dressed up but
you'd be like oh no this [__] guy
okay okay okay if you give anybody a
salad too what would it be
transported into the future to save the
world
that's good that's good what makes you
feel happy that's good
Claudio party like what are you what
you're wearing is also your energy your
vibration there you go oh I do not like
when people start talking about
vibrations dude when the second people
talk about vibrations I am for real out
when people talk about low versus high
vibrations I go oh you know what dude
this is actually been really great I'm
gonna bounce because you don't want me
to start hating
okay it's like when people just buy
things and put it on you can tell what
they really feel in their heart versus
what their mind told them was gonna get
the look
I mean the guy dude damn dude damn
you could tell when people buy things
and just put them on versus you know
buying them because they really feel
that damn
dude the two biggest idiots that have
ever spoken to each other
I just feel that you can sense that yes
it's a feeling yes yeah it's for you
okay you know what I'm saying and you
know last but not least like you know
you gotta think about others bro I mean
do you and think about last but I gave
one example and then to last but not
least the guy is on another planet
a planet that [__] is not even out
yet
uh
uh but he's cool I think you know he's
cool no obviously jokes dude no hate
guys [__]
that's a cool dude
but also the Watchers
there's a couple getting married she
puts cake in space
Oh I mean just assaulted her straight up
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's fine
she's straight up assaulted her okay
in his face cute as [__]
it's so insane oh hit her dude I mean
you know just smashed or broke her nose
doesn't give a [__]
well
wow
oh [__] there was a guy I love this guy
on uh
I love this guy ass Pizza
who does the [__]
names are crazy huh
I saw ask Pizza he's a designer he did I
think he got his big break with Kanye's
merch
doing Kanye's merch
um
uh and uh
his name's ass pizza and he's a designer
and
so I uh I saw him once at the this place
I was walking by and we both were like
hey what's up oh hey what's up I was
like I like I like your [__] and he was
like yeah I like your [__] or whatever
the [__] I don't remember and um
anyway
he's a designer he makes cool jackets
and [__] and this guy
this is hilarious I love this guy for
this
but this is what he says
I'm gonna let you in on a little secret
no one else is gonna freaking tell you
because they are [__] Liars said
fricking and I'm talking with a brand
wondering oh where do I get blanks to
print on I don't know it's so expensive
these jeans right here I've been
printing on these jeans my whole life
don't tell anyone this all these jeans
here
directly from Walmart look buy all the
jeans 13 bucks a pair print on them we
replace the button sew the tag up I've
gotten a lot of my stuff at Walmart
stuff like that guys it's easy as that
all these other brands are [__]
scamming you I'm going to tell you the
truth my jeans they're all margins yeah
so what doesn't matter these other
brands they pay two cents for a thing
and charge you 79 million dollars such a
markup
[Music]
don't worry guys we're gonna pick it up
I love Walmart
I'm not with that Haha [__] come in here
destroy the store no respect people and
respect others someone got to clean this
[__] up I'm gonna pick it up
I'll be seeing them tick tocks get me
tight [__] you
yeah nice dude it's so good because
people are so mad because they feel like
they got ripped off and it's like hey
babes capitalism and I don't say this a
lot but hey capitalism's my baby
um this is what everyone does and you're
mad because and they say because he
charges 220 for the jeans and it's like
but he's the artist dude he prints his
art on the jeans you buy them for 220.
that's the way it goes dude hey
capitalism my babies dude and now I want
to do it what he did that's awesome I
want to do it so basically just because
I saw that I'm a jeans artist now
I think that's great man
just [__] getting G's from Walmart
sticking a [__] hearty star on it and
just selling it for 220 hey dude he
tricked ya everybody's tricking
everybody you think that [__] bags
cost 800 you think bags cost nine
thousand dollars no they don't they
tricked you it's a brand name dude I
have a brand
speaking of which we got new [__]
merch it's awesome it's [__] grow or
die merge you get it off the back of the
[__] shoulders it's absolutely ill
dude oh dude everyone's starting the
back of the [__] [__] with the
letters they all started in they all
started here where the where the
where the uh shoulder starts dude
that's absolutely [__] hilarious I'm
a little different than your neighbors
okay I started over here dude I started
further over on the [__] shoulder man
I started on the delt the gross [__]
starts and it goes all the way over to
the other side on this down and so when
people say is it on the back I just go
like this
yes but that's not where it starts I'm a
little different than your neighbors and
so now you can go and you get the hoodie
and rep that [__] dude because if you're
not growing you're dying I also have a
regular where it's on the front and
there's the wilted flower but either way
dude you're popping you put this [__] on
you're popping I wear it out people go
where did you get that and I go like
this get it
I made it
foreign
so that's what's up man and uh you can
get them there chrisley.com he tell go
get it and then wear it on tour come
come see me on tour uh but it's all good
dude and I talk about it and I talk
about it and that's the commercial I
suppose even though it's not because
it's me
um
dude
this is apparently uh
the LA Philharmonic right La
Philharmonic I always thought that was a
weird uh
saying thing to say but during Czech
Gorski how do you say it
Tchaikovsky oh well that's an R
Tchaikovsky right I know Tchaikovsky I
get it
Fifth Symphony wow can't even say
Symphony at the LA Philharmonic do you
mean these words during Tchaikovsky's
Fifth Symphony at the LA Philharmonic
last night apparently a woman had a full
body orgasm just from the music it was
it was recorded
um I wish there was video of this I mean
I would be laughing so hard so let's
hear this a woman had an orgasm because
of Music which by the way do you believe
in that [__] I know some people say you
can now like I know like you know they
say you can slow your heart rate down to
where the EKGs don't even read it well
like like a game like James Bond did it
once you know and it would just go Boop
you Flatline but really he was just put
himself under for a little bit because
he was so good at it and then when the
bad guys weren't looking he made his
heart start pumping again and then
kicked the [__] out all the bad guys
that happened in the James Bond movie so
you know it's true but can you have an
orgasm just by chilling I want to know
uh
and she also waited for the greatest
moment where it was just I mean
wow that's a woman it sounds like a guy
that's how you know she was really like
when a woman sounds like a guy
oh God that's a woman when a woman's
just like
oh God like a Will Ferrell character oh
oh my God
that's when you know that being was
smashed dude
so she was just sitting listening to
music yeah but she was probably sitting
on her being a little bit right
Will Ferrell
Will Ferrell dude ah
um
that's right dude if I was
if I was if that was my date dude this
is what you would hear if it was me and
my my date this is what you hear if it
was it was Kristen right here that's
what you're here
that's right that's what you'd hear dude
right there
I lay it down that's me dude right there
watch
yup and I ain't even touching her that's
that's that's me dude
it's my check right there that's it
that's me dude that's me right there
[__] got it like that
like that wow man also the fact that the
music brought her to orgasm and it was
that song you know not even just like
like just elevator music straight up wow
the LA Philharmonic [__] sucks you
know
it's so uncomfortable there too and you
got to listen to [__] grown men with
big ass instruments dude the fact that
instruments are so big some of them you
know like the oboe and the bass and [__]
just so big like make them smaller it's
two thousand and [__] 23. you still
gotta carry around a big ass bass and
just like
you use your fingers [__]
playing the Seinfeld music
sorry dude I love that song
that's right that's me that's my [__]
yo
somebody said that's a crazy Flex he'd
been there for 130 years and
Tchaikovsky's still satisfying the
ladies
it's right man that's me
that's what I can do if I want
um
wow I can't believe that that's amazing
dude oh God Pedro Pascal arrived in
[__] what's it called the little
Annoying [__] shirt is he gonna be
wearing
guys you can wear like airplane wings or
some [__] here we go here he is here he
is there he is there he is wow such a
fast clip I love it
four people
[Applause]
wow just a Streaker a Streaker he's
dressed like a [__] honestly
he's dressed like a Streaker in in in in
Dick Tracy he was just like a Streaker
in Dick Tracy okay
um there you go Pedro Pascal slicked
hair slick back
just [__] gaze the days long and fine
and that's fine I love gays I wish I was
I don't know if he is or not I'm just
joking but um I mean pretty much
everyone's gay if you go to the mega
you're gay for at least then
um
let's do some uh some of these
let's do some misconnections here Emily
Deschanel Santa Monica huh I mean just
airing it out dude that's the subject
airing it out hey this one's for Emily
Deschanel well sorry we [__] Expo we
dockster you're beautiful intelligent
with a great personality your compassion
knows no bounds your passion for causes
for the causes you believe in is
admirable you use Twitter to draw
attention to the problems that plague
Society you are the best and the perfect
women I mean Jesus dude
is she gonna check it
oh she's an actress oh she's [__]
yeah the one from uh
Jesus dude that goes uh hey man just
tweet her you know
she's the one in uh bones
God you're so good in Bones speaking of
Bones I'd love to take my bone
uh weird thing to put on misconnections
you know imagine Emily Deschanel just
scrolling through misconnections like oh
[__] wait a minute hold on a second
guy from Bones come here look at this
let's just [__] name that guy
how's that guy that famous for so long
that famous you know how did he not get
more famous than he is that's what I
want to know
the guy did one [__] movie about
fishing and then did Bones and then that
was it dude he did one movie about
fishing with Brad Pitt in it
somewhere the [__] night is or
whatever the hell it's called what the
hell is it called another [__] One
Bites the Dust what the hell that's
called
the first guy next door what the [__] is
that
a river runs through it got it without
any help dude A River Runs Through It
dude and um
did that movie and then did Bones for 47
years
did born dude what Andrea Andreas branis
Michael bolianisk Michael corleones
Andreas Bocelli
David Boreanaz and [__] yeah I was so
close how much
no
didn't get famous from River Runs
Through It
no what's he in
he's the best of the best I thought that
that was David Boreanaz for this whole
[__] time
holy [__] it's the same guy dude they
were separated at Birth
how is David Boreanaz that famous though
for real how did he not get then he did
some show called SWAT or some [__] David
boreanis dude how much does David
boreanis cheat without discretion
[Laughter]
and his wife caught him and he goes like
this he says
they want me
what like literally said what and she's
like you can't do that he literally went
and he said what
they want me and thought that that would
be the end of it I thought she would be
like oh okay
all right here we go younger seeks male
role model
not really used to having an older male
figure like a father role model wait
hold on not really used to have an older
male figure like a father role model so
giving this a shot younger guy here
looking for a good sense of discipline
and direction in life and to get better
maybe even go for a run and here's where
it takes a turn or
wrestle that's creepy tell me more about
that
dude you know
I really used to look hey man just at a
dinner party uh you know what dude you
know what I'm into man I'm not really
used to having an older male figure like
a father role model in my life so I'm
giving this a shot man you know I'm just
like a young guy I'm kind of looking for
a good sense of discipline and direction
in life get better you know maybe even
go for a run or you know what wrestle
that's creepy tell me more about that
anyway will you pass the um
here we go smooth bottom piece of the
puzzle Montebello
this is written like a haiku form hello
so please don't waste my time I'm for
I'm looking for a puzzle piece smooth
bottom kind oh wow it is Argo I'm
looking for CDs will also
well
I can't travel but I can host you at
night seriously send pic of Sirius
[Laughter]
maybe he means if serious hello hey guy
proofreaded hello so please don't waste
my time I'm looking for a puzzle piece
smooth body I like how it
they tried to rhyme and for two times
and then that's it I'm looking for CDs
will also do other guy wow that was a
good one
what is wrong with everyone you know
wow this is a good one just left your
yard sale Derek
uptown Whittier subject
yes it should fit I could stop by when
the coast is clear and see if your hose
is a go
short and sweet we know what it's all
about obviously they had a conversation
there yeah it could fit
unreal all right well dude you know what
that's it for this uh week's episode
thank you very much you guys are great I
got the new dates up Chris christie.com
go there to get tickets get the new
grower dimers don't forget and also dude
it will be really dope if you left a
comment in the algorithm uh if you left
a comment under And subscribe subscribes
and all this and that's it for the
YouTube episode if you want to watch the
raw uncut the unedited version uh and
it's a doozy today on uh on patreon go
over to patreon.com crystalia and you
can get that and all of the and every
episode every uh month we have an uh an
extra episode only on patreon that's
exclusive to patreon you get involved
with that when you get on the patreon
and we've done about 27 of them or so so
if you go get uh the patreon now you can
have access to all the all the backlog
patreon only episodes and that's four
only six bucks so patreon.com Crystal
yeah thank you very much for listening
[Music]
thank you